في اسره تهوى الفروسيه نشا رودلفو كانت له
شغفا منذ الطفوله فقرر امتطاء شغفه وان
حاله بينه وبين ميوله الاعاقه اصابه في سن
الثالثه عشره بالتهاب السحايا البكتي
باطرافه علج مرضه لكنه فقد اصابع يده
وصل طريقه وتعلم كيف يروض الخيول اصرار
كوفي بالحصول على ميداليه اولمبيه وها هو
اليوم يطمح للقب في مسابقه الفروسيه في
الدوحه برازيلي من اصول عربيه يقول ان
وجوده في الدوحه يشبه العوده الى الديار
في الواقع يمكن رؤيه تاثير الثقافه على
الفروسيه في هذه المنطقه كنا نرى الخيول
العربيه فقط الان نرى الاعتناء بانواع
اخرى مثل خيول الرياضيه ومن الرائع رؤيه
كيف تمكنوا من امتلاك افضل ما في النوعين
وافضل بنيه
في البطوله ثلاث منافسات الترويض والترويض
الخاص بذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه ومسابقات
القفز على الحواجز لا تجتمع هذه المنافسات
الثلاث في بطوله واحده الا في خمس دول فقط
في العالم وقطر واحده منها وقد بدات
البطوله تكتسب زخما دوليا كبيرا حيث
يتنافس في هذه الدوره متبارون من ثمان
وعشرين دوله المعايير المطلوبه ليست
بالسهله وما شاء الله ميادين الشجب
الموجوده
في الشقب هذه تحفه معماريه سيتحدث عنها
يعني ما شاء الله اجيال قادمه منذ عشره
نسخ ونحن ننظم هذه البطوله ونتميز بها
فهذه مثل ما تقول يعني جوهره بطولات
الفروسيه في المنطقه
التزام وانضباط لسنوات يتطلبه الفوز في
هذه المنافسات وفي المنطقه العربيه ما
تزال الفروسيه والاهتمام بالخيل جزءا
اصيلا في ثقافتها وتحاول هذه الدوره وهي
العاشره بث هذه الثقافه لدى الاجيال
الصاعده لم يكن ردولف محظوظا بالفوز في
هذه الدوره لكنه يامل ان تكون مشاركته
حافزا للشباب والاطفال على رفع الهمم
ومنازله الصعاب ومزاوله الفروسيه التي
تجاوز من خلالها صعوبات الاعاقه لا حدود
الاعمار المتبارين في هذه الحلبات
متنافسون في عقودهم السادسه مع اطفال
بالكاد تجاوزوا العاشره هنا تتراكم
الخبرات وتتلاح الثقافات في البطوله
الوحيده من نوعها التي تنظم جنوب الكره
الارضيه
ياسين الجزيره الدوحه